if you want to lose weight the most
common advice
you tend to hear is to ditch rice
totally
because eating rice can make you fat
is rice really the culprit does rice
deserve
the bad rap it has been getting firstly
let's get some facts right rice is not
fattening
nor is it unhealthy have you ever asked
yourself
if rice makes people fat then why are
majority of the people in east
asia slim despite eating rice on a daily
basis
rice is a staple diet to more than half
of the world's population
and 90 of the world's rice comes from
asia
rice is a rich source of carbohydrates
and fiber which are essential to a
balanced and nutritious diet
it is also low in fat and sugar easily
digestible
gluten free and a good source of b
vitamins
personally i used to be afraid of rice
but after getting to know the benefits
and purpose
now i eat rice every single day
and if you have seen my transformation
rice has helped with my energy level
improve my workouts and even reduce my
body fat
so yes you can enjoy rice and still lose
weight
and maintain a healthy weight for life
i'm sure
you're watching this video and wondering
how can i include
rice into my diet and lose weight if
you're a rice lover and don't want to
give up on rice
while losing weight here's how you can
do it
to manipulate your weight up or
down it comes down to one simple
principle
of energy balance to lose weight you
have to create a negative energy balance
that means you should be burning more
calories
than what you're consuming on the other
hand to gain weight
you have to create a positive energy
balance that means
you should be consuming more than what
you're burning
so the main reason you're gaining weight
is not because of rice
but rather is the total amount of food
you consume in a day for example
if your body is burning 2 000 calories
in a day
but you're consuming a total of 2 and
500 calories
that's when weight gain happens in order
to lose weight
you need to either reduce your food
intake or
increase your activity level or both
if you're unsure about how much you
should eat in order to lose weight
then go to my channel and watch the
video on learning to count
your food portions and macros yes
you can eat rice but you still need to
practice
portion control if you continue to eat
heaps of rice
and blaming it all arise because you're
gaining weight well
that's because you're not practicing
proper portion control
so how much should you be eating
if your goal is to lose weight keep it
to one to
two small balls a day this here is
a small bowl okay one small bowl of
cooked rice has typically between
200 to 250 calories depending on the
type of rice you're using
and because rice is rich in
carbohydrates you can skip
other forms of starchy cups in the meal
in which you're having a serving of rice
one of the reasons that rice tends to be
labeled as
bad is because of its high glycemic
index that means that it is digested
very quickly which can cause sudden
spikes in your blood sugar levels
as a result this may leave you feeling
hungry again
and could lead to eating more calories
later on
you can avoid this by pairing it with
lots of vegetables as well as protein
vegetables are high in fiber which will
help you to stay full for longer
do remember that a balanced diet should
still be
half of vegetables quarter protein and
quarter starchy cups
which in this case will be rice
as i've mentioned before rice on its own
can be healthy
but not when you turn it into a bowl of
oily fried rice or flavoring it with
butter
heavy cream or ghee that's going to add
extra fats
sugar and calories which is not going to
help with your waistline if you consume
it regularly
just like a piece of chicken breast it
is a whole healthy food isn't it
but not when you deep fry it so your
cooking methods
matter a lot choose to boil your rice
plain
if you do want to flavor it then be
mindful of what
and the amount you're using
this is specifically for endomorphs if
you're an endomorph then you tend to be
more
insulin resistant and have a lower
carbohydrate tolerance
you do better on higher protein and fats
with
lower cups so you have to be more
strategic
in planning when to eat rice
because your body doesn't tolerate cups
very well the best method
is to avoid high or starchy cups food
outside of your workout window only
consume starchy foods such as
rice whole grain breads quinoa corn
barley yams or potatoes after exercising
your body tolerates and processes
carbohydrates most efficiently
in the three hour window post workout
so this is your best time to eat your
starchy
cups eating cups after exercise will
replenish
your glycogen stores which you have used
up during your workout
but remember that you still need to
practice
portion control that also means outside
of the workout window
your diet should consist mainly of
protein healthy fats and vegetables
to learn more about body types and the
right exercises and food to eat
do watch my video on my youtube channel
on how to exercise and eat according to
your body type
so the next question is what type of
rice should i eat
can i eat white rice or do i
only have to eat brown rice brown rice
is considered to be healthier than
white rice and the main reason is that
this rice
is unpolished brown rice is definitely
more nutritious compared to white rice
it is high in fiber protein vitamins and
minerals
saying that however nowadays
manufacturers do enrich
white rice to replace the nutrients lost
during processing
most people can tolerate both brown and
white rice however
there are some people who find it harder
to digest brown rice
including myself personally i consume
white rice more often or i would mix
both
brown and white rice together this makes
it
easier for my body to digest there are
lots of different types of rice out
there
but the nutritional values between them
wouldn't differ too much
if you ask me what rice should i consume
my simple answer is to consume one that
you enjoy
and it's easily available i love
rice rice is a grain that is easy to
prepare and it's incredibly versatile as
well
it can be cooked in a variety of ways it
is widely available
and it's very cheap i've created a lot
of different rice recipes over the years
which you can watch on my youtube
channel i've also put together a list of
healthy rice recipes
for you to try and start introducing
rice in your diet
all the links will be in my description
box below sustainable weight loss is a
combination of regular exercise
and a healthy diet you don't have to
give up your favorite or staple foods
like rice while you're trying to lose
weight practicing portion control and
using healthier cooking methods to cook
your meals
are extremely important are you a rice
lover
do let me know in the comments below if
you enjoyed this video if you find this
video to be useful
then do give this video a thumbs up
share this on with your friends
and do also hit the subscribe button on
my youtube channel
go on to my channel and check out a lot
more home workout videos
healthy recipes as well as nutritional
tips
and i will see you next time all the
best
don't be afraid of rice